Android 6.0 marshmallow brought a major
change to androids permission model
instead of asking for all permissions
that install time it introduced a
runtime permission model letting you
control when your app ask for a
permission when and how you ask for a
permission is critical it's kind of like
asking someone out on a date doing it
too soon too often or in the wrong way
isn't going to go well for you I'm Nick
butcher and in this video I'll walk you
through the details of androids runtime
permission model and show you how to
design a UX for asking for permission
that's appropriate to your apps needs
now the purpose of permissions is to
protect your users privacy when you ask
for permission you're asking them to
give up a little bit of that privacy and
as such you need to offer a clear and
equal benefit in exchange for that
access runtime permissions allow you to
choose the right time to ask for
permission when the user has more
context about why you're requesting it
and the benefits of granting you might
be familiar with runtime permissions
from other platforms such as the web but
the way that Android implements them
makes it incredibly important to answer
them in just the right way you see
Androids permission model favors
protecting the user so when your app
requests a permission Android chose a
dialog letting the user accept or deny
it but it also lets them say never let
this app ask me for this permission
again now you'll want to avoid this
outcome so we've designed the system to
effectively let you ask for permissions
without having to be overly defensive
the very first time you request a
permission we don't show that dreaded
never ask again checkbox we'll only show
it after users denied a permission
request at least once you can check if
you've been denied before and be smart
about when to provide more education
this lets you build a smooth journey
through your app only adding extra steps
or information when needed in particular
you don't need to be too defensive like
always screening for interest before
actually requesting a permission
essentially asking twice this double
prompting can be unnecessary and
annoying and you can achieve the same
effect by asking at the right time and
in the right way we break down the
different approaches to asking for
missions across two dimensions firstly
how important is the permission to your
apps operation and secondly how clear is
it why you're asking for it depending on
these two factors we recommend different
approaches to how you ask for the
permission if the need for a permission
is both critical to your app and obvious
why it's needed then we recommend asking
upfront for example if you're making an
SMS app then the SMS permission is
absolutely critical for you to function
and it's crystal clear why you're asking
for it don't bother your users with any
unnecessary explanations just request
the permissions straight away if a
permission is really important to your
app but not immediately obvious why then
we recommend educating before asking if
your app uses some kind of user
onboarding then this would be a great
opportunity to tell them about this
killer feature then go ahead and ask for
the permission so for example if a key
part of your note-taking app is that it
logs the location where you made a note
you'd want to educate your users about
that upfront and then ask for the
permission next up if a secondary
feature of your app needs a permission
but it's clear why then ask in context
for example if your note-taking app lets
you dictate an audio note then it's
pretty clear why this feature would need
the record audio permission there's no
need to bombard your user too early with
this request better to wait until they
try to use the feature when it will be
immediately obvious why you're prompting
for it finally if a feature is not
caught your apps purpose and not
immediately obvious why it's requested
then you should educate in context so
for example if your note-taking app lets
you collaborate with friends then
requesting access to your contacts might
be reasonable but it isn't immediately
obvious and would benefit from some user
education when the user invokes a
feature offer some explanation of the
benefits allows like Auto completing
email addresses and then let the user
opt into it only then asking for
permission by using the right approach
it should be clear to the user why
you're requesting a permission
what they get for it in return this
doesn't however mean that they'll grant
the permission a hundred percent of the
time so how should you handle denial
now remember Android lets you know if
the user has previously denied a
permission so that you can show more
rationale to educate them on why you're
asking and the benefits of granting if a
user denies a critical permission then
explain why you can't proceed without it
and link to your apps settings page
where they can rectify it
don't just shutdown now this is
especially important as the user may
have checked that never ask again box so
your app may receive the permission
denial without the user seeing the
permission dialog and it could seem like
the interaction was just ignored another
pro tip is to always show the user
immediate benefit when they grant your
permission like we said this is a
trade-off of access for functionality so
for example if you're granted access to
the users contacts then you could
immediately present the list of their
favorite contacts for quick selection
finally while you're taking stock with
the permissions your app uses perhaps
revisit if you need the permission at
all Android offers facilities for apps
to talk to each other letting you
delegate tasks to other apps for example
if you want to allow users to take a
photo but it isn't a core part of your
app consider using intents to ask the
camera app to take the photo and share
it back to you voila no need for the
camera permission so that's androids
runtime permissions model in a nutshell
and some approaches to asking for
permissions now they understand how it
works you can craft the perfect flow for
weather when and how to ask for
permissions maximizing your chance of
your users agreeing to hook up with your
app thanks for watching for more
information check out these links